good morning believe nation today's
message is get in the arena over the you
Conan O'Brien EV go what astounds me is
how many young people come up to me and
say Conan some dang to be on your show
man I say me too what do you owe what is
it you do yeah they don't know that's
the crazy thing most people it's the
Paris Hilton phenomenon they just want
to be famous and they've actually seen
it work they've seen a number they've
seen someone get a Baretta being famous
for just being famous so that's a little
unsettling sometimes but mostly what
what what I've noticed or what I would
say to people is you've got to go to
where they're making the thing that you
like and then work there in any capacity
you know if you have to get coffee for
somebody if you have to hold a cable if
you have to stand there and volunteer go
to where they're making the thing that
you that moves you that gets you excited
and try and get close to it and I mean I
remembered for years i was aware that
i'm not doing the thing that is going to
be my life's work but I'm close I
couldn't you know I couldn't even tell
you exactly what it was but I knew I was
close do not I mean I was rude I knew
when I was a writer at Sarah net live
this isn't quite it but I'm close I knew
when I was a writer in the Simpsons this
is further away from it than i was at
CERN out live I knew that I liked being
around the live performing or the you
know so I knew when I was close I just
in and and that's what I tell them is
just go there and don't have an ego
about it there's so many channels now so
many stations just exactly what I tell
ya and just get in the arena is the idea
if you get it a percent i was getting in
the arena get in there and do it and uh
and eventually it's just the Brownian
movement of molecules eventually you
getting in there and doing putting
yourself out there if you have something
to offer someone's going to see it at
some point
and you're off and running I get this at
least every day at least every single
day somebody out there in believe nation
leaves a comment on one of my videos
that says one day you're going to
profile me in your top ten and listen I
love it I would love nothing more than
for you guys to have such a big impact
on the world that people are shouting
your name that people are tearing down
the walls to get to me to say Evan you
need to profile this person that would
make me so happy that you're out there
having that kind of impact but having
the goal isn't enough for all of you who
have at home this goal list of
everything you're going to accomplish
having the goal is not enough you have
to do the work because you could be
talented at whatever it is you do you
have genius level talent at something
but unless you're out there doing the
work you're never going to get the
results of your after that gold sheet is
just gonna stay a goal sheet for the
rest of your life until you start taking
action look at me I could be the best in
the world at making motivational videos
that help inspire entrepreneurs maybe
that's what I have genius level talent
at if I was not out there creating
videos for you guys then that genius
just stays within me and for a lot of
you guys that genius will die within you
for a lot of you guys that genius will
never be brought into the world you'll
never have the impact that you want to
have and somebody with far less talent
than you will have a much bigger impact
in you because they are out there doing
the work they're out there in the arena
I'm here making videos for you guys five
times a day I'm doing the work and it
helps me get better every time I do it
you need to be prolific in the creation
of your work as well you need to not
just get in the arena once a week or
once a month you got to get into the
arena every single day and fight and
grind and learn and improve and get
better and beat on your craft until you
are one of the best in the world until
you're having that impact that you want
to have and then you're able to cross
those things up the list so I love the
big thinking I love the goals I love
that you want to get on my top ten i
love that you want to be a millionaire
or whatever it is that you set for your
list
goals but I want you to actually start
hitting your goals I don't want you to
be in the same place that you are next
year making the new set of goals and the
exact same ones that you had last year
because you didn't cross any of them off
the list and that counts of you actually
getting into the arena and doing it and
doing it and doing it you have to take
action because talent alone is not
enough so the question of the day today
is are you getting into the arena enough
leave it in the comments below I'm going
to join in the discussion thank you guys
so much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and i'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events besa
expresso give me